wäre man in so einer situation ehrlich
dann wird man sagen warum ist das so
unangenehm dass du mich krass gekauft
hast etwas glaubt jetzt willkommen beim
ein video wie man sie ich habe heute mal
wieder eine etwas andere location statt
ihr könnt ja in die kommentare schreiben
was euch besser gefällt also mein zimmer
oder das hier schreibe meine kommentare
ich finde irgendwie ganz entspannt so
auch mal zu sitzen ich will aber auch
gar nicht angelaufen wir kommen
direktwahl zum thema und zu habe ich mir
für heute überlegt so ich kann ja schon
sagen so dass die meisten meiner
zuschauer halt weiblich sind ist ja so
und da hab ich mir hey was kannst du
denn mal machen was euch wirklich so
brennend interessiert und bin dann auf
die idee gekommen erzählt doch einfach
mal wobei wir jungs wirklich immer also
ich will jetzt hier nichts
verallgemeinern
klar kann ich jetzt nicht sagen dass
wirklich jeder junge immer bei genau
diesen sachen liegt aber es sind ohne
scheiß 95 bis 99 die dabei wirklich
immer lügen ja ich würde sagen wir legen
direkt mal los bin noch einen zweiten
teil sehen wollt könnt ihr das ja am
ende des videos mit einem daumen nach
oben mir zeigen oder in die kommentare
schreiben
let's go und ja ich weiß muss wieder zum
friseur morgen hab hier in friesoythe
okay leute kommen wir zum ersten punkt
und zwar wenn jetzt euer freund oder
junge sagen euer freund genau wenn der
jetzt an dem und dem tag nicht kann weil
er es mit seinen ganzen freunden macht
halt wirklich nur freunde keine
freundinnen sondern nur freunde nur
jungs und ihr aber auch was mit ihr
machen wollte und dann fragt haye kann
ich nicht mitkommen und er dann sagt ja
klar kannst du mitkommen das ist eine
lüge 100 prozent ich schwöre 100 prozent
ist das gelogen
ich mein man will halt auch manchmal nur
was mit seinen jungs freunden machen
boys kollegen bruce so deswegen kann ich
euch mädchen da jetzt nur raten wirklich
akzeptiert das so wenn er ab und zu mal
sagt ja ich mache was mit meinem freund
fragt einfach gar nicht nach ob ihr auch
dabei sein dürfte kann es auch jungs
geben die euch dann unbedingt dabei
haben wollen das wird dann den freunden
von eurem freund aber auch den sack
gehen richtig auf den sack gehen weil
man will halt auch mal was eine unter
jungs machen ist also das passt ja jetzt
eigentlich schon ziemlich gut zum
nächsten punkt und zwar wenn er zum
beispiel die freunde von eurem freund
dich nicht mögen
du weißt wirklich ja ich habe vielleicht
das und das nicht so gut gemacht oder
vielleicht ist es ja auch einfach
grundlos aber sie mögen dich nicht und
wenn dann euer freund sagt er ist mir
doch scheissegal was meine freunde
denken das ist auch gelogen weil es wird
ihm niemals scheiß egal sein er will
nämlich vor seinen freunden cool
dastehen oder klar
das kann man so und so gesehen aber
verlasst euch nicht auf die aussage
juckt mich nicht was meine freunde über
dich sagen du bist wichtiger als die
oder so ähnlich dass mit dem wichtiger
kann sein aber das mit juckt mich nicht
was sie über dich sagen das stimmt nicht
hundertprozentig nicht nein einfach nein
der nächste punkt ist jetzt vielleicht
für den einen oder anderen mit für das
eine oder andere mädchen von euch also
für euch jetzt so fit für die meisten
warum sollte man als junge gerade so ein
video gucken ich meine was juckt euch
das wenn jungs mögen das wisst ihr doch
selber auf jeden fall ihr werdet ihr es
vielleicht etwas überrascht sein aber
das ist eigentlich auch so und zwar ich
rede jetzt davon sehr privaten
vielleicht schon so sexuellen inhalten
für steh dir wenn da jemand so ich sage
also wahrscheinlich euer freund oder
eure ich weiß ja nicht was bei euch so
abgeht da draußen aber solche dinge rede
ich nicht mit meinen freunden privat und
das sage ich den nicht
ich will mit solchen sachen auch nicht
angeben und so alles klar
lüge 100 auch gelogen ich meine jeder
junge sagt okay vielleicht sich zu allen
seinen freund aber zu seinen besten
freunden sagt er was er so alles sich
geklärt hat wen wann wo was so versteht
ihr es ja auch so vielleicht das kann
man sich auch ein bisschen denken oder
ich meine was denkt ihr denn okay leute
kommen wir zur nächsten lüge die spiele
ich in meinem freundeskreis auf so
krassen rolle da kommt man so in der
woche eigentlich nicht drum rum um diese
lüge also ich krieg das selbst mit
obwohl ich ein junge bin acht dass das
erzählen mir halt meine freunde so dass
ballert man immer raus wenn irgendwas
falsch gelaufen ist zb mann war jetzt
feiern sagen wenn man das waren jetzt so
auch freundin dabei und man hat von der
einen den übelsten korb kassiert
wirklichen krassen corp dann kann man am
nächsten tag immer noch die ausrede
benutzen was sie eigentlich keine
ausrede sein soll aber das muss man als
mädchen auf checken ich mein so was wie
sorry ich war betrunken ding ist doch
eigentlich wenn man besoffen ist dann
macht man immer oder man sagt immer die
wahrheit und man macht auch jetzt nicht
er genau man macht sachen die man im
normalen zustand gerne machen
arbeite ich da nicht traut so ist das ja
deswegen kann man doch nicht sagen sorry
ich war besoffen und deswegen habe ich
das und das gemacht wäre man in so einer
situation ehrlich dann wird man sagen
bei mir ist das so unangenehm dass du
mich krass gekauft hast aber nichts
anderes ganz einfach und ich glaube
jetzt kommt schon die fünfte sache
belassen was jetzt auch erstmal bei fünf
dinge auf jeden fall das fünfte ist wenn
es jetzt ab und zu mal mit eurem freund
um seine ex freundin geht und er dann
sagt ja meine extremen war voll scheiße
dieser auch richtig das ist doch auch
alles gelogen ich meine das ist doch
logisch du bist doch damit nur selber
ich mein wenn du bei deiner ex freundin
sagt dass die scheiße war du warst mit
der zusammen dann kannst du ja nicht
sagen die war scheiße das ergibt einfach
keinen sinn ist eine lüge ihr könnt
nicht sagen oder wenn ihr jetzt als
mädchen von eurem freund hört eine
ex-freundin die war so scheiße die war
potthässlich geht doch gar nicht man
beim kopfball gegen seinen kopf und
fragt warum warst du dann mit der eulen
zusammen ja so ist das leider bei uns
jung ihr könnt ihr auch als mensch mal
in die kommentare schreiben wobei ihr
immer liegt dann kann ich dazu
vielleicht auch mal wieder machen das
ein bisschen kommentieren ansonsten 16
feier ist auf jeden fall nach oben da
dann sehe ich natürlich und es gibt
bestimmt auch noch zweite folge weil es
gibt mega viel so wobei wir halt lügen
und sap alles eingeblendet hier oben
links geht es doch weiter mit meinem
letzten video könnt ihr auch auf jeden
fall mal abstecken das war dinge die die
niemals zu deiner freundin sagen
solltest schaut mal rein da oben und wir
sehen uns dann am nächsten sonntag
wieder ich wünsche einen schönen tag
veränderte